lieux de méditation aussi pour certains
tout au moins que le parc de la tête
d'or méditation sur une nature à ranger
à l'idée des hommes car même le voyageur
anonyme de ce bateau qui fend les eaux
du lac ne peut rester insensible à la
poésie de ce paysage lyonnais
pas plus que ne peut rester insensible
cette poésie ce preneur familiale qui a
loué un bateau pour faire le tour de son
là
votez des sous bois au petit matin ou
dans la chaleur écrasante de midi
c'était d'un premier amour
calme du pêcheur on fixe un
rassemblement son bouchon poésie dieu
pont échange les serments tout cela
c'est le parc de la tête d'or et puis la
loire que bon celui des amateurs de golf
miniature celui des assoiffés qui la
fraîcheur des sous voie n'a pas été
suffisante
et enfin troisième visage du parc celui
des animaux car toujours le spectacle de
ces animaux qui souvent ressemble
tellement étrangement aux hommes attirer
les spectateurs et les spectateurs de
tous âges et de toutes conditions
n'est-elle pas belle cette île aux
oiseaux mais toujours celui qui a su
retenir les enfants c'est le petit âne